you are watching ColdFusion TV
hi welcome to another ColdFusion video
so in this video I'm just going to be
talking to you a bit about the note 7
and the recent exploding battery debacle
the note 7 was supposed to be a story of
refinement the moment when years of
experimentation trial and error seems to
converge on the perfect size function
and form for a large screen phone tablet
Samsung's marketing campaign engine was
firing on all cylinders only to have the
product that they were selling burst
into flames while charging due to a
battery defect with the iPhone sevens
release just around the corner this
couldn't have come for a worse time for
samsung mobile the exploding phones
weren't due to 40 charging cables
it was the faulty devices themselves one
man from Perth Australia had his note 7
explode charring his hotel room
bedsheets and carpets the hotel charged
him almost two thousand dollars for
damages and Samsung agreed to pay
Samsung has issued some statements on
the problem as well as issuing a recall
and temporary halting of sales according
to reports Samsung designed the Galaxy
Note 7 battery cell but the production
was delegated to third parties it's
claimed that one of these third-party
manufacturers has produced the battery
and present in faulty units the
technical details haven't been released
yet but perhaps it's fair that the
battery manufacturer takes on some of
the costs of the recall and that's not
going to be cheap we'll talk about the
cost later the following is a statement
from a Samsung spokesperson quote as a
September 1st a total of 35 claims were
registered with Samsung's service
centres at home and abroad only 24 units
on a scale of 1 million were affected by
the battery problem by putting our top
priority on consumer safety we've
decided to halt sales of the Galaxy Note
7 and offer new replacement handsets to
all customers end quote it's said that
two point five million Galaxy Note 7
handsets have already been sold and will
need to be recalled as a part of this
exploding battery fault so what does
this mean for Samsung
when asked about the recalls financial
impact on the company Samsung's mobile
chief codon Jen said it would be a
heartbreaking amount and quote the
recall and phone replacement to 2.5
million note owners is set to cost
Samsung at least 1 billion dollars by
some analysts estimates while this
sounds like a lot for Samsung that only
represents about 5% of the firm's net
income for 2016 not ideal but not the
end of the road for the company either
however the cost is not only in lost
inventory their market value and
consumer confidence will also take a hit
investor concerns saw the share price
drop in reaction to the news Samsung's
market share initially dropped by 7
billion dollars when the news was first
announced before regaining some ground
that being said this kind of volatility
is expected as the speculative markets
of today are extremely twitchy all that
I've mentioned hasn't included the
competition even with no headphone jack
the new iPhone 7 rumored to have three
gigabytes of RAM and a 25% faster CPU as
well as larger storage options will take
advantage of some of the lost potential
Samsung sales the whole scenario could
just be a blessing for Apple
so in conclusion even though this is a
third-party manufacturers fault it's
still a Samsung branded phone and they
should have tested all of this during
the quality control phase of production
before actually selling the product as
highlighted earlier consumer confidence
will be damaged and I personally can
imagine many risk-averse type of
individuals staying away from the note 7
even when the problem has been fixed
depending on the consumers memory this
could hurt Samsung well into Christmas
sales all in all all those similar kind
of things have happened to other phone
manufacturers this is the worst thing
yet to happen to Samsung mobile and will
take at least a few months with a duster
clearer so yeah those were my thoughts
in the note 7 fiasco I've had a few
people ask me to cover it so I just
thought I'd give my thoughts thanks for
watching this quick video subscribe to
the channel if you're new and has a very
important side note if you haven't seen
my last video you're missing out in one
of the best videos I've made this year
so you should really check it out I'll
leave a link below cheers guys this has
been - go go you've been watching cold
fusion and
you again soon for the next video
imagine having one of the greatest
inventions of the 20th century in your
hands and giving it away because you
didn't understand where you were holding
cold Gideon are you thinking
[Music]
you
[Music]